okay so after a week-long recess the
johnny depp and amber her defamation
trial returned this week to see a major
change in dynamics headed up by camille
vasquez the amber heard
cross-examination really got into the
nitty-gritty of hurden depp's
relationship as well as the external
things about that case i cast a lot of
doubt over her credibility in our first
breakdown of the trial we talked about
how lawyers are very much representative
of the person that they're hired to be
on the side of for example deppenhood's
marriage counselor discussed how amber
would talk over johnny in the sessions
and because of this he didn't really
have a voice throughout his testimony
amber's team kept objecting whilst he
was recounting their time together and
at points they would constantly
interrupt him we talked about how this
could plant the idea in the jury that
the stories about depth were true and
how he didn't have a voice this week
depp's team definitely took a strategy
that subliminally helped them out with
the cross-examination by having camille
go first she had very quick fire
delivery in which she talk about a topic
get the answer that made her look like
she'd been lying and then move on to the
next topic at some points it just seemed
like a bombardment of rapid-fire
questions slowly unraveling her
statement and i think having camille do
this was the best way to go about it
it's very easy to seem sexist when
talking about this trial and i know
myself that i've had to basically try
and second guess what i'm saying because
it could come across in a certain way
that basically derails the whole video
so very clever to just avoid this all
right off the bat and have camille do
the initial cross-examination now there
were also some discrepancies in the
finalizing of head's testimony that made
people on social media question whether
she'd been sticking to the rules during
the recess it's illegal to talk to one's
counsel in order to straighten out
certain elements of a story however herd
and her lawyers start off the final
statement and her testimony by
correcting a lot of dates and errors it
did appear like they'd gone over the
internet and possibly tried to correct
mistakes which might be something the
jiri consider when coming to a decision
there was one point where she was off by
an entire year in terms of dates and it
did unravel several parts of her
testimony i am trying to stay as
unbiased as possible when making these
videos even though i do have my leanings
over who's telling the truth and i think
it's impossible for anyone to say 100
that they know exactly what happened
that's why when amber's testimony
dropped she did get a lot of support
online but i think these corrections
actually did her at her service as there
was so many that it makes you question
what else she was wrong about now we're
gonna play the main highlights of the
cross-examination day one and whilst
this is going on let me know what your
thoughts are camille brought up a lot of
her testimony and then would show photos
of her the next day and ask why she
looked and injured there was even a
point where she talked about how in her
statement she'd said that depp severely
bruised her back and then showed a
picture from a premiere the next day in
which she was wearing an open back dress
it really brought a lot of things into
question and it culminated with the
seven million dollar charity donation
heard claimed to have made she also
threw her legal team under the bus at
one point and brought up how evidence
she'd submitted hadn't been brought into
the trial and the two-hour questioning
had a lot to unpack from it bear in mind
the first part of the audio also comes
after amber publicly accused johnny mr
depp hasn't looked at you once this
entire trial has he
not that i've noticed no
you've looked at him though many times
haven't you
yes i have
you know exactly why mr deb won't look
back at you don't you
i do
he promised you he would never you would
never see his eyes again isn't that true
i don't recall if he said that
one of the last times you ever saw mr
depp was when you met him in san
francisco in july of 2016 right
that was the second to last time i saw
him yes
and this was after you had publicly
accused him of domestic violence
i got my restraining order before that
yes
and this is after you had obtained the
domestic violence restraining order
against him that's correct
let's please play plaintiff exhibit one
two two nine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
don't take my [ __ ] glasses off
you know
look at not my eyes you will not see my
eyes again
and he tells you you will not see my
eyes again doesn't he
uh yes he does in that recording and he
kept that promise hasn't he
as far as i know he cannot look at me
he won't look at you right mister
he can't
one of the first questions your counsel
asked you on direct is why are you here
do you remember that
i do
let's please play plane to exhibit 357a
which is already in evidence your honor
and for the record it's 21 22 through 21
40.
[Music]
that's your voice on that recording
right yes it is
you were speaking with mr duff
yes
and you said to mr dab quote
you can tell
you can please tell people that it was a
fair fight and see what the jury and the
judge think tell the world johnny
tell them johnny depp i johnny depp a
man
a victim two of domestic violence end
quote that's what you said right
i was saying it to the man who beat me
up yes
this was um opiate johnny
this is a different
version of him this is opiate on the nod
johnny and you weren't afraid that
opiate johnny or the monster as you
called him would get upset that you sent
this picture to your friend well he's
all of those things
he of course he could get upset and of
course that's scary to me of course
but stop you from sending this picture
to your friend did it
why would it
so in this october 2018 interview you
said that you had quote donated
end quote your entire divorce settlement
to charity right that's correct and in
fact your exact words were
quote seven million in total was donated
to i split it between the aclu and the
children's hospital of los angeles end
quote
right that's correct i made that
statement as soon as i got a divorce and
we reached the settlement that's when i
pledged it right then
and you say this because you quote
wanted nothing end quote that is correct
but you hadn't donated your entire
entire seven million dollars
settlement to charity at that point had
you that's incorrect
sitting here today ms heard you still
haven't donated the seven million
dollars divorce settlement to charity
isn't that right
incorrect i pledged the entirety
of the settlement seven million to
charity and i've
been to fulfill those obligations
that's not my question
please try to answer my question
sitting here today
you have not donated the seven million
dollars donated now pledged donated the
seven million dollars divorce settlement
to
charity i use pledge and donation
synonymous with one another but i don't
miss heard
i don't use it synonymously that's how
donations are paid misheard respectfully
that's not my question
as of today
you have not paid 3.5 million dollars of
your own money to the aclu yes or no
i have not yet
you had all of the seven million dollars
for 13 months before mr depp sued you
and you chose not to pay it to the
charities you pledged it to is that
correct i disagree with your
characterization of that
most of the money that was donated to
the aclu and chla in your name came from
someone else isn't that right
i don't know what you mean by most of
well at least five hundred thousand
dollars that was donated to the aclu in
your name wasn't paid by you right
uh i believe elon made a donation in my
honor on one one of the years yeah and
it didn't come out of your seven million
divorce settlement right no nor did it
count towards my pledge
and at least five hundred thousand
dollars that was donated to the
children's hospital of los angeles and
your name wasn't paid by you either
right those were made at the same time
and it didn't come out of your 7 million
divorce settlement nor did it count to
my
3.5 obligation those 500 000 payments
came from your new boyfriend elon musk
right
uh he i don't know if he was a new
boyfriend at the time
you got him to pay part of what you
promised to these two charities didn't
you incorrect
because you wanted to keep at least some
of the 7 million divorce settlement for
yourself right i'm very wrong about that
so lots of things to take from that and
the difference between pledging a
certain amount and actually donating it
really brought into question whether she
was doing this entire thing for her
public image or because she actually
cared on top of this amber confirmed
that her pardon aquaman 2 had been
severely reduced she said that she
initially had quite a big role but as
things got out such as the leaked audio
and images of depth injured this became
diminished heard said she received
revised script pages that cut down her
part and it lines up with a report from
grace randolph last week that she now
has 10 minutes of screen time in the
film the petition to have her removed
from the movie also just passed 4
million signatures and it's clear that
this trial has really affected the
public and industry perception of her
interestingly amber's language also
changed from her testimony initially
when she was going through things with
her own lawyer she would firmly state
this happened however this altered to
become it felt that way when she was
questioned in the cross-examination huge
shout out to the youtube channel eagle
bytes for explaining the difference in
this and why it's called a partial in
law rather than being something that can
now be confirmed we are viewing the
statement through the eyes of how amber
felt about it you're probably better off
watching actual lawyers over me but let
me know below if you think this alters
the impact of her testimony as i know
there's definitely several sides at play
here now camille and day 2 kind of
changed the pace of a bit but it was
still as effective she ended up getting
amber to admit a lot of things brought
up her statement and made her contradict
herself this completely broke down the
witness statements we'd heard in the
trial so far and it went over the
numerous accounts by people that saw her
uninjured after she said she'd been
badly hurt it brought up the police
officers and also james franco which
amber confirmed came over to her house
camille played the video twice letting
amber very much set herself up in a trap
she also denied that the op-ed was about
johnny even though she spent a lot of
time in her testimony going through the
ins and outs of their relationship this
also revealed that amber hit johnny the
night of her 30th birthday really she
also testified that two of the same
images were taken at different points of
the day even though as pam beasley would
say same picture now the second part
went over amber's reduced role in
aquaman 2 and how it was difficult to
say whether public perception had made
this change i think it's pretty clear it
did but warner brothers kind of seemed
like they're playing both sides by
keeping her in but not really giving her
a substantial role on the opposite side
of this johnny was fired instantly and
we heard last week from richard marx how
hollywood had a no tolerance policy to
actors who were accused during the metoo
movement i think that if she's found
guilty they might remove her altogether
and remember this is a studio that
re-shot about 50 of justice league
through joss whedon so i don't know how
difficult it would be to redo 10 minutes
this was clearly her trying to hammer
home that her career had been affected
as much as johnny's but we discovered
that she also had contracts with l'oreal
it's heard you're not aware of any
career opportunities that you lost as a
result of mr waldman's statements are
you
well it's kind of hard to point to the
jobs you're not offered right to the
gigs you don't get you were not
replacing aquaman 2 were you
they released me from my contract
and i fought to stay in it and they kept
me in it i just don't know how much i'm
in actually love the final cut
and you testified yesterday that l'oreal
actually extended your contract in april
of 2020. is that correct
in part they extended it and held me
and you testified yesterday that l'oreal
extended your contract again in november
of 2021 correct
not exactly they extended it because it
couldn't use me or any of the materials
uh for me
and that extension was for 20 months
right
that's correct this is from march 26
2021 right that's what it looks like yes
and this is after he made the statement
you claim the statements you claim are
defamatory right ms heard
21. yes miss heard you tweeted it adam
waldman quote yes mr waldman i may be
wearing makeup on this occasion but on
every occasion you will still be short
did i read that right
yes
we can put this down thank you
mister since your relationship with mr
deb ended you have completed your level
three sommelier training haven't you i
haven't completed it yet
i decided to
no i'm on level
three you also have had a baby right i
have and you enjoy being a mother
more than anything
i still love to cook
i do
and you love to hike
i've taken a break on hiking for a
minute you have friends right
i do have friends you spend time with
those friends
occasionally when i can
and you exercise regularly every day
you just filmed a movie in march of
2022. isn't that right
yes the one i just shot in guatemala
that i spoke of earlier and you have um
you had a major role in a major film
that's scheduled to be released soon is
that correct
aquaman two
as i said i don't know if i
will even be in the final cut or how
much i will be it was difficult to stay
in the movie now one of the main
criticisms about amber's testimony and
cross-examination online has been that
she seemed quite arrogant and smug
throughout that's kind of why i think
the waldman tweet was brought up and no
it's not really that bad of an insult
well i don't think it is anyway it's
more amber's delivery and reaction to it
i think camille was trying to bring up
they're very much trying to show the
jury the kind of personality that she
has and these tactics are all used by
the lawyers to put a certain idea into
their heads the james franco cctv
footage is also something that has
appeared online for a couple of years
now and it was used to say that amber
had been cheating on him with the actor
throughout the trial it's often been
said that a lot of dep's anger came from
accusations of cheating which her denied
we'll play the clip now though and you
can let me know below what you think of
the situation
you testified yesterday that you sought
a temporary restraining order on may 27
2016 because you wanted to change your
locks do you remember that testimony yes
i do because the locks were to the
penthouse is at the eastern columbia
building isn't that correct that's
correct
you changed the locks to the penthouses
on may 22nd 2016. i attempted to
that's why you felt comfortable having
james franco over the evening of may
22nd 2016 miss heard
i do not know when
[Music]
i do not know when james came over okay
let's remind you can we please pull up
planters exhibit 304 which is already in
evidence and play
from 254 through 439
[Music]
um
[Music]
you
uh
that's you and mr franco on may 22nd
2016 right miss heard that's correct and
you're taking him up to the penthouses
aren't you that's where i lived yes and
it's past 11 p.m at night isn't that
right i'm not quite sure the time it
looked it looked like that
why don't we pull that video back up
22 51
almost midnight right that's
excuse me almost 11 o'clock at night
exactly
okay
you knew mr depp was out of town the
week of may 21 2016 didn't you
i don't know what i knew of his schedule
at the time
knew mr depp was out of town on may 27th
when you went to get the domestic
violence restraining order isn't that
right i don't know if i knew that at the
time
you knew you knew mr depp was heading
out on a european tour that week isn't
that right i'm not quite sure what i
understood of his schedule at that time
you knew he wouldn't be back for weeks
right no that's
incorrect let's uh go back to that
recording
now a big thing in the trial is who was
the person actually behind the physical
violence and amber has been caught on
tape admitting that she lost it with
johnny this was put to her in the trial
and they also asked why her interviews
with lawyers had a completely different
demeanor to what we saw on the stand
last week this is something that many
people have brought up and there's even
videos playing these two speeches side
by side so you can see the difference in
delivery heard has been accused of
delivering her testimony like a
performance because the world is
watching and she's trying to convince
the jury of what's going on camille
vasquez posed why she was smirking and
completely different when discussing
this matter in privacy can we please
pull up plaintiff's exhibit 356.
i can't
see that i'll be perfect i can't promise
you i won't get physical again god i
just get so mad i lose it
i can
promise you i'm you know
do everything to change
promise you
i'm not going to go around divorce i
will not say divorce
unless it's it and then i hope you leave
me
i'm not going to give me two i will
leave you
it's fair i can't do it you know and i
think honestly if we hold each other
accountable to that
it's fair
that's heard that's even mr depp on that
recording correct that's correct and he
told mr deb quote i can't promise you
that i won't get physical end quote
correct that's correct he was accusing
me of instigating something in the
situation i explained yesterday
and you also told mr debt that sometimes
you get so mad you lose it correct
that's correct i also explained the
context of that fight yesterday
isn't that exactly what you told ben
king on your way back from australia
that you get so mad you lose it
absolutely not i know that that's what
ben king testified to but i never had
that conversation with ben king i
remember him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
smiling as that audio recording is being
played in your deposition aren't you
misheard not smiling because of the
audio i'm smiling because of what's
happening around me you even roll your
eyes at one point don't you i was
sitting opposite a whole table full of
lawyers who were snickering laughing and
rolling their eyes at me while i was
talking
is there something amusing about kicking
a door into your husband's head
no i was rolling my eyes and commenting
on what i was experiencing at that time
in recounting the story there's
something amusing to you about punching
your husband in the jaw
that is not what i was smiling about and
no i do not think it's amusing now the
other main accusations that have been
lobby that heard is that she's following
the padding of a toxic person that's
when out of her way to ruin johnny's
life since their divorce there's an old
saying when a toxic person can no longer
control you they'll try and control
people's perception of you which is
pretty much the basis of this defamation
case depp is saying that herd's op-ed
ruined his reputation career and public
perception which he has denied the
marriage counsellor came forth and said
that herndod posed the question of
whether it would benefit her more if she
was the one who did the accusations
first and also got ahead of the divorce
it's been stated that heard wanted to
get it out in the public that she had a
restraining order against johnny for his
abusive behavior which this next clip
plays into this would hypothetically
boost her career whilst leaving depps
behind there have been theories that had
spoke to tmz as things were filed so
that they would break the story on it
giving her an advantage and further
defaming him camille then posed the
evidence of potential slip-ups to amber
in the cross-examination this swaps
halfway through the amber's lawyer in
the video and it goes through the
allegations that amber was also abusive
to her previous partners
miss heard
did you send a text message to jerry
judge on may 24 2016
telling jerry judge quote i'm
desperately trying to reach
johnny
it's extremely important
please tell him
i remember
sending the text message that is in
front of me right now to jerry
uh
and i would like
i remember sending this because i wanted
to tell johnny
or have him told by jerry or someone who
knew him or was close to him basically i
didn't want him to find out online that
i had or was about to file or i had
already filed for divorce i wanted him
to know verbally so i was trying to
reach him through a third party
to tell him when i say reach i'm
specifically saying i would like him to
know information coming from me or
coming from jerry from me
so that he finds out about the divorce
filing
or my intention to do so
from some other source other than tmz
which was alerted
you slipped up there didn't you misheard
you let it slip out that tmz had been
alerted to your filing of the domestic
violence restraining order didn't you i
disagree that's not what i'm talking
about team z is the same outlet that you
released the video of mr depp attacking
the kitchen cabinets the day before this
deposition was taken wasn't it i didn't
do that i don't know how to do the
copyright to that video now doesn't it i
have no idea what tms do they pay you
for that
i never got paid for it because i had
nothing to do with that so tmz was just
lucky in getting the inside scoop to
your divorce from mr depp huh i have no
idea it is
not that's not my area of
expertise i wouldn't even know how to do
that
and also what does that get me if i
wanted to leak things about johnny i
could have done that in a much more
successful way in a bigger way for years
now when you were extorting him for
seven million dollars i got a fraction
of what i was entitled to in the state
of california by the way what extortion
tosavan reed's your ex-wife right
that's right she's mike's partner she's
the one that told
that you told this jury mr depp was
jealous of right
yeah well that was a 2013 fight
around march yes you testified that he
tried to burn one of her paintings right
that's correct you testified he tried to
burn
um
one of your favorite paintings that she
did right
i don't know if it was one of my
favorites
you committed domestic violence against
miss van ried during your relationship
didn't you
no i did not you assaulted her at a
seattle airport in 2009 didn't you no i
did not and people saw that
that's not true and it was covered in
the press
isn't that true it was a it was planted
in the press by johnny's team
two days after i got the tro
miss heard did ms van ray come out after
that article came in to make a public
statement it was false of course
objection your
your
honor
hearsay
be at least overruled thank you
of course she did
okay
now
let's talk about the tmz alerted explain
to the jury what you meant by the tmz
was alerted
so when you make these kind of filings
meaning divorce uh marriage things like
that they are public record
and so when we file for divorce when i
file for divorce i ask my team to file
in the most discreet way
literally to put it under a stack of
papers and file it at the end of day so
kind of had more of a shot of being
missed by the paparazzi and by tmz and
those sorts of publicity
outlets
i believe that we had been remarkably
lucky following the divorce that it
wasn't picked up and that it gave me a
precious few days
of of peace at that really fragile time
when i found out that they were
going to run the story or that they had
the information i was
trying to get a hold of johnny
to clarify
that i did not do this in a punitive way
i didn't want him to be mad at me i
didn't you know i didn't want him to
find out
in that sort of context online why did
james franco visit you on the evening of
5 22 2016.
objection calls for speculation do you
know yes please tell us because he was
my friend and he lived next door quite
literally next door and i had frankly
exhausted my support network with my
usual friends and
was happy to welcome as much friendship
at that time as i could possibly get
now the video showed him laying his head
on your shoulder can you describe for
the jury what the interaction was
without saying what was said what the
interaction was that led to that
he
after seeing my face put his actions
for speculation that doesn't call for
speculation if she sees that he sees
he touched the side of my house
okay again your honor if we can instruct
the witness if you could wait to left
the objection please all right one
question what did mr franco do
uh on the elevator before laying his
head on your shoulder
he i'm gonna touch the side of my face
and
responded now hits lawyer elaine ended
up not even getting all her questions
out at the end as objections came in
quick and fast and overall she barely
got any of her actual questions out huge
shout out as mongol for putting together
this reaction to it and you should
definitely check out his channel as he's
got much more steady updates on it than
i do objection your honor foundation all
right i'll sustain the objection next
question
and do you what if anything did you
produce to the plaintiff
in connection with your consultation
with an ent she's about to do it
relating to your nose objection leading
insisting foundation hearsay
what if anything
bro this is
what if any production
did you make
to the plaintiffs
of your medical records with the ent
objection your honor lack of foundation
[Music]
okay
do you know
whether
the records medical records oh my god
emt were produced in discovery objection
your honor lack of foundation calls for
speculation
just i mean if she knows thank you
yes okay
great we've made progress yes and
do you
do you recall
i'm trying i'm trying
um
what
if anything
ma'am the medical records
reflect about your nose objection your
honor here say how sustained the
objection do you have
injuries to your nose
yes
please describe those to the jury oh
okay now we're back in the fan fiction
i'm going to object to the extent it
calls for hearsay
and lack of foundation she's overruled
an improper expert opinion
well
she can certainly testify too
we'll see where it goes go ahead okay
we'll see where it goes
i have a significant amount of scar
tissue in my nose objection your honor
i'll sustain the objection
i don't have any more questions here all
right thank you all right ma'am you can
have a seat next to your attorney yeah i
bet 3 out of 100 questions accepted yeah
exactly that was terrible for them
that was really
man that was bad so overall pretty rocky
start of the week however heard did have
a witness come forward in her defense
but i want to save that for the next
recap we do as this is based purely on
the cross-examination and opening lots
of things to discuss and i had to cut
things out too just to keep the runtime
of this video lower let me know what you
thought below and as mentioned i did
think that it was a pretty full-on
attack on hertz testimony that poked a
lot of holes in it i think the main
issue that herd is running into is that
she has several people saying that they
never saw any injuries on her this
includes female police officers which is
probably the kind of thing that depp's
team want on the jury's mind as it rules
out the sexism angle and also holds up
that people in authority have questioned
her stories really interesting evolution
of the case and we will of course be
back probably either monday next week to
discuss about the updates so make sure
you subscribe and also if you haven't
checked out our other videos then they
will be linked on screen now thanks for
watching the recap and hopefully i see
you next time take care peace